Hoy estamos con una leyenda viva ella es
Silvia earl O sea no grafa la fundadora
de Mission Blue una organización que se
dedica a promover el cuidado del océano
Ella es una bióloga Marina y además fue
una de las primeras aconautas en bajar a
las profundidades del océano una de las
pocas mujeres en lograrlo por lo menos
en su momento Silvia es un placer estar
con usted y gracias por estar con
nosotros
gracias por invitarme usted como ya lo
decíamos fue una de las primeras
aquanautas y ha pasado días enteros
semanas enteras en las profundidades del
mar a más de 200 metros 1000 metros de
profundidad y en otras oportunidades ha
dicho que las especies tienen mucho que
decirnos a los humanos Qué es ese
mensaje que nos dan y cómo cuidarlos
océanos
es que el cambio ha sido muy rápido
desde que comencé a explorar el océano
como una joven científica usando una
escafandra y luego viviendo en
laboratorios debajo del agua usando
decenas de submarinos para ir más allá
de la profundidad desde entonces
muchísimas cosas han cambiado
90% de los tiburones atunes y meros y
muchas otras especies que antes eran
abundante ahora desaparecieron las
tomamos las comimos dañamos sus hogares
utilizando técnicas de pesca que son muy
destructivas armatostes para raspar el
suelo oceánico y destruirlo como si
usáramos excavadoras en las ciudades
cerca de la mitad de los arrecifes de
coral que alguna vez existieron a
también están destruidos una combinación
de la crisis climática y podemos ver en
nosotros la causa principal del Rápido
cambio en la temperatura y también la
química del océano las aguas marinas
Ahora son más ácidas Y esto no genera un
ambiente amigable ni para los corales ni
para muchas otras criaturas
ese cambio no es bueno pero el otro
cambio que sí es positivo es que ahora
sabemos mucho más del océano de lo que
habíamos sabido antes en toda la
historia de la humanidad y es porque
hemos sido capaces de explorar el océano
relacionarnos con las ballenas y los
grandes peces los arrecifes de coral los
bosques de algas y sumergirnos en la
máxima profundidad del océano Y es que
después de todo el promedio de
profundidad es cerca de cuatro
kilómetros
como usted lo dice nunca antes en la
humanidad habíamos sabido tanto del
océano y a la vez nunca lo habíamos
dañado tanto qué piensa Entonces al
respecto sobre la llamada economía azul
que todavía seguimos sacando provecho
del océano a pesar de de todo este daño
que ya le hemos hecho
quita el descubrimiento más importante
sobre el océano en el tiempo en el que
estado viva es la magnitud de lo que no
sabemos el tamaño de nuestra
ignorancias
Entonces tenemos que ser muy precavidos
sobre explotar más cuando realmente no
sabemos las consecuencias nos aceleramos
para tomar y tomar consecuencias que no
son buenas para nosotros
y según esto qué piensa de la minería en
el fondo del mar que es otro método de
seguir explotando y que la idea es
encontrar minerales supuestamente para
promover la energía verde no hay un
dilema ahí en explotar más el océano
para transitar a una energía verde en la
tierra
mientras dañamos la salud de los deanos
dañamos nuestro propio futuro Entonces
cuando pensamos en un nuevo esfuerzo de
la escala de la minería en el fondo del
mar no es una buena idea irrumpir en
esos sistemas que son vitales para la
salud de nuestros océanos y de nuestra
salud
y en ese caso la tecnología se
utilizaría para interrumpir o dañar esos
ecosistemas pero no siempre la
tecnología ha sido mala para los océanos
y como usted ya lo decía es el momento
en el que más sabemos de ellos también
nos mencionó las profundidades que usted
ha conocido gracias a esa tecnología y
de hecho en 1992 usted fundó el Deep
Ocean exploration and res con el que
creó diferentes tecnologías para poder
explorar el océano Cómo esas tecnologías
pueden ayudarnos a combatir la crisis
climática que tanto está impactando los
océanos y segundo qué piensa de métodos
propuestos por ejemplo para captura de
carbón en el mar
lanzando químicos por ejemplo también
para reducir el pH de los océanos que
son cada vez más ácidos
creo que lo más importante que podemos
hacer por el océano es seguirlo
explorando para entender la naturaleza
de la vida y Cómo afecta a la generación
de oxígeno la captura de carbono los
ciclos de la vida
todo desde el ciclo del oxígeno al
nitrógeno toda la manera en la que
funciona el planeta está anclada al
océano solo hemos explorado y visto
quizás un 10%
del 90% restante sabemos a tan poco que
ni siquiera hemos mapeado el océano con
la misma exactitud con la que lo hemos
hecho en la luna Marte Júpiter
[Música]
Hemos descuidado el océano porque lo
damos por sentado nuestra prioridad
Entonces es continuar la exploración y
básicamente respetar la integridad de
estos sistemas interconectados
no sabemos cómo repararlos Entonces
dejémoslos en paz aprendamos de ellos
[Música]
no queremos Perder el conocimiento que
está allí tan solo por la codicia y los
intereses cortoplacistas que tienen
consecuencias catastróficas a largo
plazo
[Música]
y en esa investigación de los océanos
que usted tanto dice que es importante
el papel de las mujeres Sobre todo como
usted ha sido fundamental porque usted
ayudó a cambiar el rol y a darle un
espacio a la científicas que querían
explorar las profundidades del océano lo
hizo no solo como una de las primeras
aquanautas en los años 70 sino que
además fue la primera mujer en dirigir
el noa que es el organismo de océanos y
atmósfera en Estados Unidos dedicado
precisamente a estudiar estos Campos y
además pues la fundadora de Mission Blue
Cómo ayudó a usted a replantear ese
papel de la mujer sobre todo porque
usted siendo aquanauta les preguntaban
hasta por el labial que ustedes usaban
cuando se sumergían
lo que aprendí de mis padres cuando era
niña era que existían obstáculos para mí
como mujer al hacer cosas que mis
hermanos sí podían hacer naturalmente
pero ellos me alentaron a que cuando la
gente me dijera que no podía hacerlo yo
responderá Por qué no algunas veces hay
una buena razón pero si hay algún camino
por donde seguir continuar
quería ser científica desde niña leía
libros sobre científicos la mayoría
hombres pero pensaba que quería hacer
eso quería usar submarinos explorar el
océano saberlo todo sobre la naturaleza
y mis padres me permitieron continuar en
esa vida como consecuencia yo era la
única mujer en las clases de la
universidad Porque hay muchas otras las
desalentaron les dijeron que no podían
hacerlo y yo dije por qué
novedad
usted cometió todos esos prejuicios y
sin embargo tuvo que enfrentar
realidades que muchas mujeres en todo el
mundo tienen que hacer y por ejemplo
usted tuvo que posponer un poco su
doctorado para criar a sus dos hijos y
casarse como enfrentar esa cotidianidad
de de conformar la familia pero sin
dejar atrás la especialización en la
profesión
pues tan solo sin Rendirse nunca
Durante los 10 años cuando tuve mis dos
primeros hijos tuve un lugar en casa
donde podía seguir trabajando en mi
sueño de explorar el océano y tener mi
pequeño laboratorio en un cuarto
mis colegas tenían grandes laboratorios
en las universidades pero yo mantenía mi
sueño vivo A mi manera y mi consejo es
que si está en tu corazón lo que sea
como ciencia música arte solo Crea tu
propio camino vuélvelo tu cotidianidad
solo continúa y nunca pierdas la pasión
que tienes en mi caso al final pude
encontrar un espacio junto a mis colegas
hombres que tomaron una ruta diferente
para llegar al mismo sitio
y para terminar Qué mensaje le daría
nuestra audiencia de cómo pueden ellos
proteger el océano
primero que todo la actitud hacia el
océano debe cambiar para ser respetuosa
y entender que un océano viviente es
necesario para nuestro éxito
dependemos de su salud Porque influye en
el clima es el hogar de la mayoría de la
vida del planeta
[Música]
lo segundo es tomar esa preocupación por
el océano Y protegerlo tanto como se
pueda sin matar cosas sino dejando que
la naturaleza prospere
parece tan simple necesitamos a la
naturaleza los sistemas vivientes para
sobrevivir y nuestra naturaleza en
tierra y agua Nos necesita Somos la
causa del problema pero también la
solución
Silvia ha sido un honor estar con usted
el placer es mío por estar aquí hablando
por el océano y con este mensaje de
hablarle a los océanos de parte de
Silvia Gracias por estar con nosotros
sigan en France 24
[Música]